I GOT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
LAST WEEK WITH EVERYTHING
THAT WAS GOING ON IN THE
WORLD, AND BALTIMORE IN
PARTICULAR, IT WAS A TOUGH ONE,
A LOT OF CHAOS, CONFUSION.
SO I HAPPY TO GET A GOOD
WEEKEND, AND COMING IN TODAY,
I WAS FEELING FRESH, FRESH
START, I FELT GOOD.
>> NEWS BREAKING OVERNIGHT
FROM TEXAS.
TWO HEAVILY ARMED MEN OPENED
FIRE AT AN EVENT FEATURING A
CARTOON CONTEST.
>> BOTH SUSPECTS ARE DEAD
AFTER BEING SHOT BY POLICE
OFFICERS.
>> Jon: SO, SO MY WEEKEND
WAS GOOD UNTIL-- [BLEEP]
WELL, LISTEN THANK GOD NO
INNOCENT PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
BUT WHO SHOOTS UP A CARTOON
CONTEST?
GRANTED ZIGGY IS NOT WHAT IT
USED TO BE.
BUT UM, AND YOU KNOW, I THINK
GARFIELD HAS BEEN COASTING FOR A
LONG TIME.
FAMILY CIRCUS, THOSE AREN'T
EVEN JOKES IT IS LIKE AN
ACTUAL CIRCUS, IT SEEKS TO
ENTERTAIN BUT IT REALLY JUST
FILLS YOU WITH SADNESS.
BUT THAT'S --
SO WHAT KIND OF CARTOON
CONTEST THERE, AS IF I DON'T
KNOW, WOULD PROVOKE SUCH A
VIOLENT REACTION?
>> A GROUP CALLED AMERICAN
FREEDOM DEFENSE INITIATIVE
NOTORIOUS FOR ITS
ANTI-ISLAMIC VIEWS HOSTING
THIS AWARD CEREMONY TO GIVE
MORE THAN $10,000 TO THE
BEST CARTOON DEPICTING THE
PROPHET MUHAMMAD.
>> Jon: SEE THAT
IS-- THAT IS [BLEEP] CRAZY.
$10,000 TO A CARTOONIST?
(LAUGHTER)
THAT'S LIKE FIVE YEAR'S
SALARY.
THAT CARTOONIST COULD ALMOST
CONSIDER QUITTING THEIR TWO
OTHER JOBS.
AT TWO DIFFERENT COLD BREW
COFFEE SHOPS.
WELL, YOU KNOW, THAT'S THAT
GROUP AFDI, THAT IS THE SAME
GROUP THAT LEAD PROTESTS
AGAINST THE SO-CALLED
GROUND ZERO MOSQUE AND
HAS BEEN PLASTERING
NEW YORK SUBWAYS WITH
ANTI-ISLAMIC ADVERTISEMENTS.
AFDI IS A FIRST AMENDMENT
GROUP THE SAME WAY PEOPLE
FROM PHILLY ARE SPORTS
FANS.
OSTENSIBLY THEY LIKE SPORTS,
BUT REALLY, THEY'RE JUST
LOOKING FOR AN EXCUSE TO
PUNCH A STRANGER AND POUR
BEER ON SOMEONE'S BABY.
SO BUT EVEN SO, EVEN SO, I
CAN'T BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
REITERATE THIS.
IT IS NOT OKAY TO SHOOT
OTHER PEOPLE BECAUSE YOU ARE
OFFENDED BY WHAT THEY DRAW,
EVEN IF THEY DREW IT TO
OFFEND YOU, NO SHOOTING OF
THEM.
NEVER OKAY TO SHOOT PEOPLE,
NEVER, EVER OKAY.
>> OKAY, WELL-- HOLD UP,
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
JON, WHAT IF I LIKE REALLY
DON'T LIKE THEM.
>> Jon: YOU CANNOT SHOOT
PEOPLE!
>> OKAY.
YEAH, FINE.
>> Jon: YOU CANNOT SHOOT
PEOPLE.
YOU CANNOT SHOOT PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T SHARE
THEIR OPINION.
YOU CANNOT SHOOT PEOPLE EVEN
IF THEY OFFEND YOU.
>> WHAT IF-- WHAT IF I, LIKE,
HAVEN'T SHOT ANYONE IN A
LONG TIME?
>> Jon: NO.
STILL NOT OKAY.
>> OKAY.
>> Jon: NOT EVEN IF THOSE
PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY SET OUT
TO PROVOKE YOU, RESPONDING
TO CARTOONS OR WORDS OR
IDEAS WITH VIOLENCE IS WRONG!
>> BUT WHAT IF SOMEONE IS
CREATING A CLIMATE OF HATE
AND INTOLERANCE BY APPEALING
TO PEOPLE'S BASEST FEARS.
BECAUSE THEN YOU JUST GOT
TO-- .
>> Jon: NO!
NO, YOU CAN'T-- NO, NO!
THE VIOLENCE JUST
PERPETUATES THE FEAR.
YOU CAN'T.
THANK YOU.
>> OH.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: AREN'T YOU GOING TO
GO BACK DOWN WITH THE REST
OF THEM.
OR ARE YOU JUST GOING
TO --
>> IT'S KIND OF CRAMMED DOWN
HERE, I'M JUST GOING TO HANG
OUT HERE, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
>> OKAY BUT LIKE, ALSO, JON--
(LAUGHTER)
WHAT IF IT'S LIKE DEER
HUNTING SEASON AND I REALLY
THOUGHT THAT THAT CARTOON
CONTEST WAS LIKE A DEER, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> Jon: NO SHOOTING THERE IS
NO SHOOTING OF PEOPLE!
THERE IS NO SHOOTING OF--
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> I AGREE WITH YOU, JON, WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SHOOT
PEOPLE.
>> Jon: NO, I SAID -- AND AL
MADRIGAL, I HAVEN'T SEEN YOU IN
LIKE SIX MONTHS.
WHEN, WHEN DID YOU GET HERE?
>> I'VE BEEN DOWN HERE THE
WHOLE TIME, MAN.
>> Jon: AND WHERE IS THIS
PIZZA COMING FROM.=?
ARE YOU GUYS HAVING A PARTY
UNDER MY DESK AND YOU DIDN'T
EVEN INVITE ME?
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> MORE OF LIKE AN IMPROMPTU
THING, REALLY.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT, IT
WAS JUST LIKE A SMALL THING,
YOU KNOW.
>> TOTALLY SMALL. IT'S A SMALL
--
>> YOU GUYS!
ARE MISSING OUT ON THE --
ON THE PIZZA!
MISSING THAT PIZZA.
(LAUGHTER)
WHOOO! WHOOO! WHOOO!
>> Jon: GET OUT OF HERE, SHOO ,
SKAT, ALL YOU GUYS,
GET OUT OF HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Jon: JUST GO. CAN'T SHOOT
PEOPLE!
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
SHOOT PEOPLE.
I HOPE THAT SETTLES IT.
NOW THE QUESTION OF COURSE
WAS YESTERDAY'S ATTACK IN
TEXAS AN ISOLATED INCIDENT
OR PART OF A MORE MENACING
TREND BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT THIS
FICTIONALLY FOR A WHILE NOW.
>> AT LEAST TEN ISIS FIGHTERS
HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT COMING OVER THE MEXICAN
BORDER IN TEXAS.
>> ISIS KNOCKING ON OUR
TEXAS BORDER.
>> Jon: OH, WELL THAT'S EASY --
JUST DON'T ANSWER.
WHEN ISIS KNOCKS, YOU JUST SHUT
THE LIGHTS OUT AND LIE
THERE.
BUT NEVER FEAR, UNCLE SAM IS TO
THE GOING TO LET ISIS RING
AND RUN YOU, TEXAS.
IN FACT, NOT ONLY IS THE
U.S. MILITARY CONDUCTING
TRAINING OPS RIGHT NOW FOR
MISSIONS AGAINST
ISIS-LIKE GROUPS, GUESS WHERE
THEY ARE DOING WITH THEM.
>> TEXAS IS ONE OF SEVEN
STATES WHERE THE EXERCISES
WILL BE HELD.
>> THE SPECIALS FORCES TRAINING
OPERATION CALLED JADE HELM
15.
>> Jon: OH, JADE HELM 15, I
HAVE THAT ISSUE.
IT'S-- IT'S-- IMPRISONS CAPTAIN
AMERICAN JADEOPOLIS, I THINK --
REST EASY, TEXAS! GOOD GUYS WITH
GUNS ARE ON THE CASE.
>> CONSPIRACY THEORIES ARE
ONE RUNNING WILD TONIGHT ABOUT
THE ARMY'S PLAN FOR A MULTISTATE
TRAINING EXERCISE THIS
SUMMER CALLED JADE HELM 15.
WHILE THE MILITARY SAYS IT'S
JUST TRAINING SOLDIERS FOR
THE REALITIES OF WAR,
CRITICS SAY THE ARMY IS
PREPARING FOR MODERN DAY
MARTIAL LAW.
>> SOME ARE CALLING IT A
TEXAS TAKEOVER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: YOU KNOW WHO IS
CALLING IT A TEXAS
TAKEOVER?
LONE STAR LUNATICS.
DALLAS [BLEEP] AND HOUSTON
[BLEEP] HOLES.
TEXAS, THERE IS NO TEXAS
TAKEOVER.
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
ALREADY CONTROLS TEXAS.
SINCE LIKE THE 1840s. AND THEN
HE LEFT AND HE CAME
BACK AND -- JUST BORROW A
TEXTBOOK FROM A NEIGHBORING
STATE, IT IS ALL IN THERE.
HERE IS HOW UNBELLIGERENT --
HERE IS HOW UNBELLIGERENT THE
U.S. MILITARY IS TOWARDS
TEXAS.
THEY SENT A LIEUTENANT
COLONEL TO A LOCAL TEXAS
TOWN HALL TO WASTE HIS TIME.
>> ALL WE WANT TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT OUR GUYS ARE
TRAINED FOR COMBAT OVERSEAS.
>> IT IS A PREPARATION FOR
MARTIAL LAW.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE IT IS NOT A
PREPARATION FOR MARTIAL LAW,
SIR.
>> THAT IS WHAT YOU SAY.
>> WE REALLY, TRULY WANT-- .
>> Jon: YOU SEE THAT RIGHT
THERE?
THAT RIGHT THERE?
THAT IS THE FACE OF SOMEONE
REALIZING THEY'RE NOT
GETTING AROUND THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THE PLANNED
PARKING LOT DOWN BY KROGERS,
NOT TODAY.
NOT IN THIS MEETING.
>> Jon: BUT COME ON CRAZY
PEOPLE ATTEND LOCAL TOWN
HALL MEETING ISN'T A TEXAS
SPECIFIC STORY, I BELIEVE THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS YOU
CAN'T HOLD A TOWN HALL
MEETING WITHOUT CRAZY PEOPLE.
I THINK IT'S IN THERE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS BEING
TAKEN SERIOUSLY BY ANYONE
WHO HOLDS ACTUAL POWER.
>> ON TUESDAY GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT ORDERED THE TEXAS
STATE GUARD TO MONITOR
MILITARY PERSONNEL MOVEMENTS
AND TRAINING EXERCISE
SCHEDULES AND ENSURE THAT
SAFETY AND CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF TEXANS WERE NOT
BEING VIOLATED.
>> Jon: OH DEAR LORD.
(LAUGHTER)
YET ANOTHER WASTE OF
TEXAS FUNDS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN SPENT ON ACTUAL THREATS
LIKE YOUR INFAMOUS CHAINSAW
MASSACRES.
I MEAN, TEXAS, IT'S NOT AS IF I
DON'T FIND IT ADORABLE THAT
YOUR GOVERNOR THINKS YOUR
STATE GUARD COULD TAKE ON THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY. IT'S
LIKE A LITTLE DOG GROWLING AT A
BIG DOG OR-- OR AN
EIGHT-YEAR-OLD PICKING A
FIGHT WITH THE PREDATOR.
BUT ENOUGH OF THE
FEARMONGERING.
YOU KNOW THESE TYPES OF
EXERCISES HAVE BEEN GOING ON
IN TEXAS FOR YEARS, RIGHT?
>> YOU'RE GONNA HAVE MARINE AIR
OUT HERE, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
MARINE GROUND, ARMY
GROUND,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE AIR FORCE
HERE, NAVY AIR, ALL FIGHTING
JOINTLY, IT'S GOOD EXERCISE.
>> YEAH, IN TEXAS! OPERATION
ROVING SANDS.
IN FACT THE 2001
ROVING SANDS OPERATION WAS
THE LARGEST EXERCISE OF ITS
KIND IN HISTORY.
BUT DID THEN PRE-OOPS GOVERNOR
RICK PERRY START SPREADING FEAR
ABOUT A TEXAS TAKEOVER?
HE DID NOT.
TEXAS WAS FINE WITH THE
CONCEPT OF WIDESPREAD
MILITARY OPERATIONS IN THEIR
STATE.
IN THE 20-OTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAS
CHANGED SINCE THEN, OH,
RIGHT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> AMERICA ELECTED A BRUTAL
SOCIALIST MUSLIM KENYAN
INEFFECTIVE HARVARD SCHOOLED
CONSTITUTIONAL PROFESSOR
AGITATOR WARLOCK.
SO TEXAS-- IT APPEARS, IT
APPEARS YOU ARE ON THE VERGE
OF BEING TAKEN OVER BY ISIS
OR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
SO YOU HAVE A CHOICE TO MAKE.
AND WHEN YOU MAKE IT, JUST
REMIND YOURSELF, AND I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD BE SAYING
THIS, WHAT WOULD RICK PERRY
DO?